pour les états unis qui se retire les
normes internationales pour eux c'est
déjà une tendance
il ne respectait pas le plan national
c'est que le plus dangereux c'est que
les américains quand ils se retirent des
accords internationaux il mais c'est
quand même d'utiliser ces normes
par exemple se soit retiré de l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien ce qui est très
préoccupant pour nous aujourd'hui nous
avons et l'échec ce sujet mais nous
avons des positions connues mais nous
allons poursuivre la coopération à cet
égard que l'iran avait posté un appel à
tous à respecter la transparence y
compris est dans le cadre de la quad qui
ne respectent pas les principes de l'art
et essai de détruire
l'accord nous croyons qu'ils ne doivent
pas utiliser ces shows live
à cet égard je les chante aujourd'hui
nous sommes pas prêts à coopérer avec la
russie pour renforcer la transparence de
notre coopération avec l'agencé veut
utiliser d'autres moyens à nous allons à
réagir de manière appropriée en ce qui
concerne d'autres choses comme sujet et
nous nous avons un très bon âge
conversation très bonne consultation et
nous allons poursuivre cette
consultation au sein de notre commission
intergouvernementale
nous allons tenir des réunions séquence
la situation le permettra
sous le sommet d'astana
sera retenu en téléconférence et puis
nous allons organiser un souper
traditionnel aujourd'hui monsieur la
roma mais ça a approuvé l'idée
d'organiser un sommet trilatéral ait
envie de la turquie le sommet contre et
latéral sera organisée après les
conférences et dès que la situation le
permettra nous allons organiser la
coopération intelligente la russie et
l'azerbaïdjan sera discuté lors d'un
sommet et j'ai envie tu me sur la france
va participer à quatre semaines mais
cela prouve à accepter si vous êtes
indications ils disent que quand la
science permettraient entre a et je
remercie la fédération de russie mais
aussi sur la drogue
merci brice thébaud va mais aussi au nom
de dieu clément et il me faire et quoi
bon jour pour moi je n'ai sur ministre
monsieur arrive dit il ya des efforts de
la part des états unis
lisant cher c'est la pression sur les
nations unies sur ce projet là
on est à fond ses actions la fédération
de russie minée par une position très
claire et je vais encore une fois posé
cette question à monsieur la pause
comment évaluer les actions des états
unis à cet égard à ce titre monsieur
l'iran la russie quelques opérations est
possible entre c'est le même jour je me
serais france et tentative de la part
des états unis
l'accord de 2015 sur le règlement
iranien et aussi sur la résolution de
l'onu qui avaient été prises adopté à
cet égard et après le retrait des états
unis de façon unanime latéral s'est pas
compris que toutes ces possibilités qui
émanait de l'exécution honnête de cet
accord sont tombés et donc qui était
stipulé dans la résolution 22,31 des
nations unies et les tentatives des
états unis de bloquer l'exécution il
fallut besoins des clauses de cet accord
et qu'il eut m'interdise donc de
travailler avec un grand est qui qui
punissent les pays où les entreprises
qui travaillent et qui rompent l'embargo
je considère que c'est qu'il veut de
l'emploi
de moyens illégaux et ceci n'a aucune
perspective d'avenir que cela ne
permettra pas une reprise des activités
normales et l'ensemble des obligations
danse de l'iran que d autres signataires
de l'accord tout ça c'est ça fait partie
d'un ensemble cohérent sa famille et si
tout simplement on arrache une partie de
cet accord
on c'est à dire que concrètement seul
l'iran doit remplir ses obligations et
que les autres ne le font pas je suis à
vous mais quand même il faut cela on a
une rupture c'est bien les règles d'
échanges commerciaux économiques
je considère ce nouveau si vous tuez
secondes aucun spécialiste en droit
international ne peuvent ignorer le
déséquilibre de ces mesures est ce que
nous voulons c'est que aucun pays depuis
ce que détruire cet accord de 2015 sur
la fait partie ça ne rentre pas du tout
dans la logique du droit international
n'a pas posé de ses journaux
donc je sais position de washington
s'appuie sur une décision complètement
un juge libyen rien ne peut justifier
manipuler le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu d'imposer des sanctions
unilatérales ou encore une fois le
rapport du secrétaire général sur
l'exécution de 31 et passe largement le
cadre des questions traitées dans cet
accord qu'il s'agit ont notamment
j'ai un rapport au moment où ils avaient
toutes été publiées dans la presse
occidentale nouveau mode ap photo le
cias absolue de même que le rapport du
directeur de lier la tôle et au genou en
août mais qui a été une suite mais vous
lui aussi de façon tout à fait illégale
je considère que ces actions venu
jusqu'au qui consiste à coller des
prétextes officiels souvent pour mener
des attaques contre la république
islamique d'iran sont complètement
malhonnête on sait très bien qui
derrière ses idées c'est une attitude
tout à fait répréhensible
d'autres commerçants commerçante
est ce que ces messieurs bout des riches
et les membres du conseil de sécurité
ont réagir à ces appels à deux
traitements de rétif des états unis
parce que c'est de faire est-ce que
c'est probable parce que il y aura eu ni
n'atterrit réponse commune à cette
empathie pas une question monsieur
arrivent c'est parce que vous croyez que
ce soit possible de protéger l'accord
sur le nucléaire
cette situation c'est un jeune qui
concerne glissement en images laissent
que peu de route il pas quoi adressée au
secrétaire général de l'onu je peux dire
c'est que j'ai envoyée au président du
secrétaire général de l'onu du conseil
de sécurité dont je n'ai pas reçu de
réponse pour l'instant mais je pars du
principe que
donc travaillons nous avons exposé un
certain nombre d'arguments tout à fait
du changement sur ce marché je me
souviens bien je dirais que nous avons
mené
je vous aime proposer de certains
s'attendent on te fait d'arguments je me
dis qu'ils sont tout à faire peser je ne
me prononcer quant à la position
d'autres membres notamment des cinémas
européens
outre l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
mais je sais qu'ils font l'objet
aujourd'hui l'expression énorme de la
part des etats-unis qui cherchent à
utiliser
l'influencé de ces différentes activités
de commerce international
poutine et on trouvera les arguments
juridiques comment je suis timide
rassurés sur la position américaine
je peux devenir avec les sanctions de
restrictions unilatérales tout cela ne
tient pas là l'osce a voulu se moquer je
suis l'ont fait indépendamment de savoir
si on va assister ou de toute façon nous
il n'est pas question de sortir de cet
accord puisque toute décision
je voudrais que ces initiatives et
efforts de la fédération de russie et de
la chine
et notamment dans cette lettre
l'explication des présidents américains
n'ont pas respecté les américains
voudraient qu'ils ont toujours eu leur
approche est sous la présidence de
monsieur seguin se sont retirés de
l'accord c'est leur objectif du
gouvernement de monsieur travail était
de l'histoire sans cet accord a été
signé lundi qu'il voulait détruire la
courageuse ont même déclaré m
ces objectifs et radiations à ses très
percutant que au sens que si j'étais
rien des nations unies et d'essayer de
se garer l'accord gilles agi seul et ne
pourrait détruire cet accord mais nous
voyons que qu'elle existe et ne pouvoir
la nation fini et on voit dans ce
rapport il menace parce que les états
unis
ménages s'est même rendu à
l'international je ne peux pas je te
promets d'y agir c'est la position
américaine
nous croyons que la position présentoirs
jeu et malgré tout les faits tous les
témoignages
la coalition anti mn de cette liste des
organisations et je les fais montre qu'
ils détruisent le droit international et
exerce la pression sur les sept les
périodes et dans une section
internationale
nous avons toujours exprimé notre
position nous travaillons en
transparence avec les quinze rames soir
que nous avons présentés à lagence
montre que nous respectons pleinement
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien ne
coopérant avec la chance mais ils
n'accepteront aucune coupure un soin à
ossun taxes des dix opus de survie
document
qui sont liées aux os ce qui ménage et
nous respectons la transparence et nous
sommes très reconnaissants à la russie
pour les actions pour les efforts visant
à rembourser à la haine mais nous
n'acceptons pas que la us soit utilisée
comme moyen du tout en visant à saper
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien ou
ministre pour briser les principes qui
sont à la base des organisations
internationales
c'est dernier trois ans sous la
présidence de monsieur tremplin nous
voyons qu'il serait dire des obligations
internationales que ce soit le côté ciel
ouvert l'indignation mondiale de la
santé et la convention de paris et
d'autres accords internationaux et nous
n'acceptons pas ce que ce pic qui se
retire des accords internationaux puces
utilisées les organisations
internationales pour exercer la pression
sur les reins j'ai entièrement bonjour
j'ai une question concernant les
frontières et quand allez-vous les
frontières à monsieur lapointe monsieur
série es ce que vous avez négocié ce que
j'ai commencé
tout lisse et les frontières seront
elles ouvertes côté c'est important pour
les hommes d'affaires sur la reprise de
ses activités normales les échanges
économiques culturels ou touristiques et
autres motifs
cela ne rentre pas dans les compétences
du mystère affaires étrangères ne
faudrait pas nous chercher nous oppose
mais à prendre des mesures qui relèvent
les questions sanitaires
nous sommes en contact nous avons
aujourd'hui vous le voyez la possibilité
de respecter les règles et tout en se
voyant entre quat'zyeux mais tout cela
toutes ces mesures dépendront de la
décision des autorités sanitaires
ça fait comme mais cela prouve là dit il
ya des préoccupations concernant la
santé des iraniens des russes c'est
pourquoi nous croyons que j'étais très
important de montignac à la bonne santé
mais nous avons poursuivi la coopération
tant dans la pandémie et nous allons
donc suivre inscrits pour ça les
dialogues
oui mais il y à un dialogue entre les
ministères de la santé y compris en ce
qui concerne les voyages etc
nous allons poursuivre les consultations
bonjour j'ai une question à aux deux
ministres est ce qu'il y aura un nouveau
sommet d'astana avant la reprise du
travail du comité constitutionnel
qui on doit avoir lieu ce qui a été
annoncé hier l'influencent de votre
expérience de coopération en syrie sur
la situation en libye guinness quelle
est la position de l'iran sur les
affrontements entre messieurs
s'arrachait after en libye aujourd'hui
vous avez confirmé l'accord entre les
trois pays nombreuses du format d'astana
sur le fait que toulouse
le prochaine réunion aura lieu se
tiendra adhérents à une date que nous
fixerons ultérieurement en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation nous
soutenons la proposition consistant à ce
lieu avant la rencontre entre les trois
présidents se tienne une réunion une
visioconférence à ce moment là je pense
que assez rapidement de fond et non
celle et m a dit j lutter vous avez
demandé si cette rencontre entre les
trois présidences de se faire avant que
la réunion du comité constitutionnel
sais rien ce rennais oui je pense que
nous devrions pouvoir encore une fois
sont en régime de visioconférence nous
pourrons discuter avec le représentant
spécial du secrétaire général de l'onu
pour la libye tout pour l'attirer en ce
qui concerne la présence de deux mesures
au mieux vos mercenaires a pas que le
mouvement syrie d'entreprise je pense
qu'on peut postuler que je vais parler
de cette éventualité
puisqu'il était très simple à savoir ici
c'est qu'il est pas possible je dois
discuter fonctionnement le temps que les
parties
je voulais partir mais dans le conflit
oui je peux commencer qu'elle puisse
rencontrer quelques difficultés donc
j'ai le début le conflit dure en syrie
nous nous sommes prononcés pour qu'un
volume un dialogue avec le vent syriens
puissent se faire malheureusement au
début de notre action en faveur de ce
règlement en 2015 quand nous avons
adoptées au niveau du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu mais les décisions
nécessaires
d'où un certain nombre d'acteurs
internationaux ont promis des parties
syriennes les bons des autres mais je
suis sûr que sont le respect des
discussions sans le respect de la vienne
et et multiconfessionnel mais je pense
que tiendront compte l'expérience de la
conférence de gala qui s'est déroulé sur
ce sujet pour que tous les acteurs
internationaux du sous-continent
travailler faut bien avoir conscience de
vos des risques de plaisance et à la
table pour négocier ce que nous faisons
actuellement de discussions avec un
autre co lecture par exemple est effet
récemment savez en ce qui concerne forme
et surtout le comité constitutionnel a
lâché même quand je suis seul à prendre
a dit j'espère que la décision qui est
celle du paysage
sur ce sommet virtuel dieu avant la
rencontre j'espère que ça sera fait
quotidiennement les tenues un confort
mal mois d'août il y aura des
consultations entre le connais comme
était simple de contribuer au travail du
comité constitutionnel des 3040 up pour
assurer le bon fonctionnement de ce
comité et tous les jours quoi que c'est
possible d'organiser la téléconférence
entre les trois dirigeants avant assez
mois d'août ce qui concerne de la russie
c'est initiatives régionales
kato le projet même si lisse queen c'est
yves menât des messages qui ressemble à
l'initiative un circuit et j'espère que
ce sera une réussite et que les esprits
sont faits devant la russie et la
turquie seront efficaces ou selon ses
forces c'est justement ce que j'allais
pouvoir légitime en libye
ah et rétabliront la paix la sécurité
pour le peuple libyen
alors nous allons signer une déclaration
commune autres giron de la fédération de
russie et la fédération de russie a
battu ambri et selon miranda rami ne
voyez vous
enfants